certains des drones qui avaient visés au
dessin au moins dans le sud du pays
avait marqué dessus pour Moscou ou pour
le Kremlin donc une indication claire
que les Russes voulaient par cette
attaque de drone se venger mais comme
vous l'avez dit les systèmes de défense
antérienne ont réussi à bloquer non
seulement une partie en réalité mais la
grande majorité de ces drones 18 sur 24
s'il faut en croire leur bilan c'est
uniquement à odessac et des drones ont
atteint leur cible qui est écrit comme
un établissement éducationnel sont
provoqués de blessés et seulement une
incendie qui a été provoquée il faut
souligner que quand les Ukrainiens
disent qu'il n'y a pas de blessés il se
peut qu'en réalité il y a des blessés
militaires mais il n'y a pas de blessés
parmi les civils en tout cas donc un
succès pour les Ukrainiens encore une
fois et puis les ce sont intensifiés ces
derniers jours c'est maintenant sur les
quatre nuits de mai et trois fois il y a
eu des frappes assez massives sur
plusieurs endroits en Ukraine y compris
loin de la ligne de France est-ce que
c'est vraiment une vengeance ou quelque
chose de nouveau qu'il faut voir en ses
attaques il y a eu cette nuit on peut en
douter ça peut être aussi juste une
partie de la campagne que la Russie a
été déjà en train de faire dans le but
peut-être s'il faut croire ce que eux
ils disent de empêcher les Ukrainiens de
lancer leur contre-offensive en ciblant
des cibles militaires
l'univers quels sont les réactions des
Ukrainiens
ils sont un peu perplexes je pense
volontiers on le sait a absolument ni et
catégoriquement être à l'origine de
cette attaque de drones sur le Kremlin
la plupart des experts s'accordent à
dire que l'idée que c'était une
tentative d'assassinat de Vladimir
Poutine semble vraiment très farfelue
est-ce que il y a vraiment eu une
attente
je pense que il y a beaucoup
d'Ukrainiens qui ont toutes qui pensent
que c'est un fake d'ailleurs Agito mur
quand j'ai de poser la question à des
gens dans la rue ils ont dit que ils
pensaient plutôt que c'était un fake
mais qu'il n'était pas sûr il y a tout
de même des raisons de penser que
c'était pas juste une mise en scène
puisque la Russie a mis très très
longtemps avait agir ce qui laisse
penser plusieurs heures je veux dire ce
qui laisse penser qu'il ne savait pas
vraiment comment réagir qui n'avait pas
tout à fait préparé leur réaction et
puis comment le commenter un expert
militaire ukrainien à la radio ce matin
s'ils avaient fait ça en février 2022 on
aurait tout de suite pensé que c'était
pour avoir un prétexte pour attaquer
l'Ukraine mais là ils ont déjà attaqué
l'Ukraine on a très bien compris qu'ils
n'ont pas besoin de le texte pour mener
toutes sortes d'opérations au Ukraine et
puis ils n'ont pas non plus est-ce
qu'elle était dans le sens de déclarait
vraiment la guerre plutôt que
l'opération militaire spéciale ou
profiter de cet événement pour déclarer
la mobilisation générale ce qui pour
cette expert laissez penser que ce
n'était pas quelque chose qui avait été
planifié par le Kremlin alors par qui
est-ce que cela a pu être fait
l'hypothèse que ce soit des partisans à
l'intérieur de la Russie des opposants à
Vladimir Poutine n'est pas à exclure